[Applause]
we know each other he's a friend from
work the trailer for thor ragnarok
revealed some surprising departures from
the Marvel Cinematic Universe what have
you brought today you told me he's
engine it looks genuinely fun and light
and there's a good reason for that
the director is te Kawai TT a relative
unknown who just might be the next
Steven Spielberg ytt is a New Zealand
native who's been directing hilarious
delightful small films for the past
decade ytt has been a frequent
collaborator with fellow Kiwis Jermaine
Clement and Brad Mackenzie directing
several episodes of the cult TV show
flight of the conchords now with thor
ragnarok ytt is on the verge of entering
the realm of mega directors like JJ
Abrams Christopher Nolan and Peter
Jackson but it is YPG's work with
children where his stylistic
similarities to Spielberg are most
striking writing and directing for
children is notoriously difficult as
they can easily become too cutesy twee
or grating Spielberg is famous for
working with child actors and films like
et Jurassic Park and AI to create
believable realistic characters in the
2016 film hunt for the will Derby
Waikiki takes a classic film trope of
the grumpy old man and the precocious
child and imbues it with emotional depth
while maintaining a light fun tone
hungry that's a silly question let's
look at you as Spielberg's budgets grew
over the years he's mostly been able to
maintain a focus on small human aspects
of his characters ensuring that they
aren't lost in the vast cgi worlds that
increasingly surround them this is a
skill that New Zealand's more famous
director Peter Jackson has struggled
like ytt Jackson also started out with
micro-budget films his early movies were
far gory ER and Popey er but they had a
loose light wit that helped them stand
out Jackson struck a great balance of
epic scale in human or
Prabhat elements in the Lord of the
Rings trilogy but with his subsequent
films like King Kong and The Hobbit
prequels characters have at times felt
secondary to the massive CGI landscapes
and sentences even Spielberg has not
been immune to this trend it's too early
to tell if ytt will be able to avoid
this trap but his early work especially
the hilarious what we do in the shadows
has shown a deft understanding of
crafting exciting action set pieces that
don't sacrifice character development
sunlight accident Thor Ragnarok is his
biggest film today and it will be
exciting to see if he can join James
Gunn's work on guardians of the galaxy
in dragging the superhero genre out of
its dark self serious doldrums and imbue
it with the comedy and humanity that it
means are you looking forward to Thor
Ragnarok were you already familiar with
Kai eco Waikiki's work and our mad
ladies selling out to Marvel let us know
in the comments below and don't forget
to subscribe